in ukraine no love there right now with
russia's ruthless bombing campaign
apartment buildings in kiev were
targeted again overnight including one
not far from the presidential palace in
the southern city of mariupol ukraine
says bombs hit a theater sheltering
hundreds of displaced civilians now this
building was clearly marked as having
children inside the number of casualties
is still not known at this time
mts taeb is in laveed ukraine with more
on the story mts good morning
gail good morning well latest
intelligence reports suggest that
russia's invasion of ukraine has stalled
considerably but that hasn't stopped it
from inflicting horrific damage all
across the country a warning now some of
the images in this report are quite
distressing
in this war of attrition nothing is off
limit
not even this theater in mariupol said
to be sheltering over a thousand people
and clearly marked for bombers to see
that's the word children in russian it's
now in ruins and the loss of life still
unclear russia denies bombing the
building blaming instead a ukrainian
neo-nazi group for blowing it up but
offered no proof at a nearby hospital
the scenes of utter carnage are
painfully clear as medics do whatever
they can
but for the thousands that have died in
mariupol including the smallest just 22
days old there's nothing left to do
these are the people we could not save
this brave doctor said
the city's collapse into chaos comes as
russian soldiers encircle it
each airstrike and shelling one a minute
at times
are slowly squeezing the life out of the
once thriving southern seaport
in the eastern city of kharkiv an
inferno russian shelling hit this market
killing at least three this resident saw
it all i think there were several
rockets or grad missiles
boom boom boom and then the fire broke
out
it's a hell that has displaced millions
of ukrainians including these children
all orphans
they were rescued less than a week ago
from brutal violence in the country's
war-torn east kids was a
mental and physical disorders
natalie is a social worker here
as we were talking an air raid siren
went off
he tells the older kids to run inside
while the youngest were carefully
gathered up by their carers who guided
them down b stairs into a basement
classroom
and played games with them to try and
soothe their fears
nadia is one of the teachers
the children don't hear the sirens from
here they are hidden she says
we are safe here
these orphans may be among ukraine's
most vulnerable but they are deeply
cared for
and still managed to smile and make new
friends
even with such uncertain futures
now the children in our report remain
safe and extremely well cared for but
consider this according to the un every
second a ukrainian child is made a
refugee every second that's already one
and a half million children many of whom
have passed through here in lev to
poland towards safety vlad
mts those images are horrific and as you
said in your report it is hell as all
wars are nts thank you very much
appreciate it